ايه ده مشاهدينا تحدثنا عن امكانيه تقديم
طائرات لكيب من قبل الغرب ايضا هناك
الحديث الذي اصبح معلن الان فيه نوع من
الالتزام من قبل بعض الدول لتقديم
الدبابات هناك التعهد الالماني بتزويد
اوكرانيا باربع 10 دبابه من طراز اليوبارد
اثنين والذي اعتبر ضوء اخضر للحلفاء
لتقديم مثل هذه الدبابات لكيف فما هي
الدول التي تمتلك هذه الدبابات وفقا
لصحيفه واشنطن بوست تمتلك اوروبا الفائده
من طراز اليوبارد اثنين في المجمل 200
منها في بولندا والتي تقول انها مستعده
لتزويد اوكرانيا بخمسه عشر دبابه من
مخزونها وعلى حدود روسيا تقع فنلندا التي
لديها حوالي 200 دبابه من هذا النوع والتي
شددت على انها لا تريد ارسال الدبابات فحس
بل تريد ايضا توفير التدريب وفقا للبلوم
بيرك تمتلك ك 82 دبابه من نفس الطراز ولكن
لم يتم ذكر اي اعلان رسمي بشان ما اذا
كانت سترسل دفعه منها الى ثياب اما
البلدان الاخرى حيث يمكن العثور على هذه
الدبابات فيها فهي تركيا ب 316 دبابه
واسبانيا التي لديها
108 دبابات اما اليونان فلديها
1383 دبابه واخيرا سويسرا والتي تمتلك
1434 دبابه